Prince George Princess Charlotte and
Prince Louis bringing us a much-needed
moment of joy while putting their hands
together for eight good cause last
Thursday at 8 o'clock everyone was
encouraged to throw open their doors
throw open their windows and applaud the
people who are working around the clock
and the NHS care workers doctors and
nurses kensington palace released some
lovely footage of George Charlotte and
Louie standing in the back garden at
Anna clapping for those nurses Prince
William and Kate Middleton posted the
sweet video to their official Instagram
account on Thursday with the caption
thanking all the medical professionals
working tirelessly to help those
affected by hashtag Ovid 19 we can't get
over how grown up almost two year old
Louie looks George and Charlotte were
featured in the Cambridge's UK Mother's
Day post earlier this week but it's been
a while since we've seen the couple's
youngest kiddo
putting their lives on the line to help
others Will and Kate also showed their
support for emergency medical workers
amid the corona virus pandemic paying a
private visit to the London ambulance
services one-one-one control room last
week they are very much behind the
relief efforts and in terms of frontline
Royals we also saw Prince William launch
an emergency help fund the public's
desire to help in the wake of tragedy
needs to be managed and channeled in the
best possible way which is why the
establishment of a national emergencies
trust was so important William's message
came the same day that ET learned George
and Charlotte would begin remote
learning at home Norfolk residents they
are self isolating Anna with the
children they're being homeschooled at
the moment ahead of the school's
breaking up the easter holidays this
after the school confirmed that a few
students had been in self-isolation
while awaiting at their Cova 19 testers
William and Kate and the children are
all safe and well unfortunately the same
can't be said for all the Royals on
Wednesday Clarence House confirmed that
71 year-old Prince Charles tested
positive for corona virus according to
their statement his symptoms are mild
and he is in good spirits I must stress
that the Prince of Wales is is not
bedridden he is up at his desk he is
working he is emailing and he is feeling
very well so far we're told the 93 year
old queen is in good health but here's
what would happen hypothetically if she
were to fall ill - in a worst-case
scenario when potentially the Queen and
Prince Charles were potentially unfit to
rule then it would be down to William to
step into that situation
[Music]